I've said it once and I'll say it again
Zuma is the worst but you didn't believe
me last time so fine I'm back to prove
it once and for all I went and watched
every single episode of Paw Patrol every
spin-off and every movie to
quantitatively determine who is the
least goodest of the good boys today we
prove once and for all which Paw Patrol
member is definitively the worst pup
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show where no theory is too big no
lore is too small so exactly one year
ago I released a theory all about
Nickelodeon's hit series Paw Patrol
specifically I talked about how Ryder
the leader of the Paw Patrol was taken
advantage of poor orphan puppies in
order to create a squad of expendable
service animals ones that he could then
send into life-threatening situations as
we see in the show Ryder pays the pups
and treats and Cuddles while keeping all
the merch sales government contracts and
stolen treasure for himself thereby
powering the expansion of his canine
Corporation and lining his own Pockets
now I gotta be honest I was half
expecting a theory that dark about a
children's IP so beloved and wholesome
to draw some hate but no much to my
surprise Ryder exploiting defenseless
puppies was not the thing that triggered
people in that episode in fact most
viewers were like oh yeah I suspected
something was up with that kid
apparently y'all were just waiting for
some validation so glad I could give
voice to what we were all suspecting
this entire time time now what really
rustled feathers down in the comments
section was a passing joke that I made
about one of the pups the water rescue
pups Zuma I had the nerve to call him
dramatic pause you
what I thought was a pretty innocuous
and obviously correct series of
statements really got some of you Zuma
stands down in the comments fired up
Zuma does amazing things I can't stand
for all this Zuma slander he's the best
pup not matpat bullying Zuma for the
entire video yes map Pat bullying Zuma
for the entire video in fact Zuma should
feel lucky he got more screen time in my
single video than he's gotten across the
entirety of that series but hey you know
what I'm an open-minded guy a lot of you
disagreed with my assessment and I heard
you so I did what any sane person would
do in this sort of scenario watch every
episode of a program aimed at
preschoolers while taking meticulous
notes in a giant spreadsheet about the
ratio at which pups are utilized and the
manner at which they're called to action
all in an effort to validate my feelings
about an animated Surfer dog yeah I'm
feeling fine and perfectly in control
don't know why you're asking is there
some Universe out there where I'm being
a little too harsh on Zuma that I'm
bullying him probably not but maybe so
let's just let the numbers decide and if
the data doesn't bear that out then I
will gladly swallow my pride and admit
that I'm wrong so today I want to set
out to prove once and for all who is the
most useless pup in the PAW Patrol if we
wanted to rank him how did the core 6
line up and perhaps most importantly of
all what punishment awaits you when
you're the worst one on a team
controlled by a Cutthroat capitalist
grab your pup packs and prepare for Duty
loyal theorists Theory Patrol we're on a
roll so let's meet our contestants Paw
Patrol is all about a team of six search
and rescue puppies each of the pups has
specialized gear and vehicles designed
by their leader Ryder all individually
themed around typical Emergency Services
there's chase the police dog Skye the
aviation pup Marshall the firefighter
Rubble the construction pup Rocky for
garbage disposal and Recycling and of
course Zuma for water rescue each
Adventure has the team saving their
hometown of Adventure Bay rescuing
anyone who might be in danger and
stopping the evil mayor Humdinger from
sabotaging the city now it's important
to note that in your typical episode not
every pup is going to be used usually
writer will call out two Puffs to start
the mission and then Midway through when
things either go all through the
situation escalates another pup is added
into the mix we're pretty deep in the
cave and Jake got his footstep don't
worry Chase we'll be right there this
system me
pups are ultimately going to be used
more than others so yeah I wasn't joking
in the intro here to collect the data
for this video I went back and watched
all 406 episodes of Paw Patrol and when
you consider a typical episode is
usually two rescues you're looking at a
hefty data set but I wasn't done I also
included the three feature length
specials and the movie to track every
single time a pup is expressly called to
divert disaster I noted the number of
call outs what they were needed for and
how successful they were in their rescue
before telling it all up into this
beautiful Google Docs spreadsheet so
before we get to the pups themselves
there's one interesting thing that I
have to call out from the data across
the 800 plus Adventures there are 15
Dream rescues where the pups are
performing some mission in their sleep
usually doing something extra cool like
body swapping saving golden coconuts or
rescuing flying saucers each and every
pup gets one of these episodes well each
and every pop except for Zuma yep every
single pup helps in at least one dream
rescue but never Zuma so to everyone who
keeps insisting to me that Zuma's
helpful all yeah right in his dreams oh
wait I guess not there either but now
it's time to talk about our winner who
is the best pup is that someone he
didn't expect to complete Underdog
working their way to the top well after
looking at the numbers we find that the
number one goodest boy of all the good
boys is drum roll please it's Chase in a
surprising twist that surprise nobody I
mean like yeah of course it's Chase
across the 400 episodes three features
in the theatrical film Chase is called
out to save the day an astounding
372 times meaning that his skills are
put to good use across roughly 91 of the
Paw Patrol Cannon and when you look at
the equipment it Chase's disposal it
becomes clear why this is the case a lot
of it is just basic safety and rescue
fare Chase uses a net to catch people
from falling a ball launcher to deflect
obstacles and a megaphone to call out to
the people that they're trying to rescue
and you absolutely can't forget Chase's
standard pupmobile armed and ready with
his handy dandy winch I made fun of this
thing in the previous episode but after
running the number the winch's overuse
is even more absurd it is used across 42
separate episodes meaning that Chase's
glorified rope with a hook at the end is
key to solving one-tenth of the Patrol's
missions
foreign
season 1 and 2 were especially winch
heavy with the tool being used in a
grand total of 18 different rescues more
recent seasons have moved away from it
likely because one there's only so much
interesting stuff that a roping hook can
do but two because Chase has actually
proved himself to be the most versatile
of any of the other pups this is why I
got himself a second set of gear the spy
gear which helps Chase search for Clues
using night vision heat sensing goggles
zip lines suction cups shoes and even a
remote controlled drone seriously it is
ridiculous how tricked out Chase gets in
this show so it's safe to say that chase
deserves a spot at the top of the podium
but Chase isn't the only pup who covers
a wide array of valuable skills for
day-to-day emergencies coming in second
we have Zuma no I'm just kidding you
couldn't possibly believe that Zoom is
this high right he's gotta be in last
place nope the real number two is Sky
the aviation pop again this shouldn't
really be that big of a surprise if you
watch the show her specialty is flight
meaning that her plain and binocular
goggles are incredibly useful for
scouting above a potential disaster will
cover in a lot of ground quickly she
also has herself a harness that she uses
to airlift people stuck in higher
difficult to reach locations across
roughly 410 Paw Patrol Adventures Skies
called upon a whopping
333 times to help out a remarkable 81 of
the time in fact Ryder and the creators
of the show have clearly noticed how
valuable she is as an asset across the
big truck pups Dino Rescue Mission paw
and mighty pups themed spin-off episodes
she's called out the most to help out
over every other hero and in the latest
season of the main show she's reached
the point where she's now used more than
even chase Ryder ever the capitalist
definitely recognizes a hashtag girl
boss when he sees one and Spin Master
makers of the show certainly know how to
expand their viewing demographic after
having captured every preschool-aged boy
who could possibly watch this thing in
short Skye and Chase's dominance makes a
lot of sense searching and rescuing are
big parts of search and rescue the
backbone of the PAW Patrol's business
model so of course Chase and sky are
going to be the most useful for Ryder
from by the way it's canon in the show
that chase absolutely has a crush on Sky
one that she either chooses to flat out
ignore or is just completely oblivious
too God
Dess chicken left is okay she's okay yes
Sky's okay she's okay ah you weren't
worried no I wasn't I'm just uh glad you
saved chickaletta but from here on out
things start to get less obvious binge
watch a few of these episodes and it's
immediately clear that Ryder plays
favorites to Chase and Skye beyond that
though we start dipping into the wild
cards Believe It or Not Rocky the
garbage collector pup is actually the
third most used talk about getting
yourself a glow up in season one Rocky
tied for the least used pup alongside
Marshall and of course Zuma but season
overseas and Rocky has made himself a
huge surge clone is way out of the
literal trash Heap to carve a unique
position for himself on the team now
obviously as the garbage truck pup he's
here to clean up after any messes from
disasters but more recently he's
positioned himself as the crafty one the
one who can build or repair any Gadget
that the team needs using his claw arm
and screwdriver ranging anywhere from a
big slingshot to Butterfly Wings to a
giant banana and honestly that ability
to build is the differential theater
that's positioned him as my son Ali's
favorite pop Rocky literally started
from the bottom now he's here and when
the pups get transformed into
superheroes through the power of a magic
meteor don't ask Rocky gets the coolest
moveset transforming into the Green
Lantern using giant glowing Fix-It tools
all of this adds up to Rocky getting
called upon for 291 rescues a huge 71 of
the time cementing him as a solid bronze
medalist in our usefulness Awards now I
don't know about you guys but I've
started to see a pattern emerge here
becoming fairly clear that more General
pup skill set is the more value that
they have within the Paw Patrol Chase is
a great all-rounder Sky's Aviation
abilities are useful in almost any
scenario Rocky's ability to fix things
will be needed basically every Mission
so what about with the back half of our
group here well you see their usages are
much lower than our first three
contestants mostly because each one is
so specialized digging putting out fires
doing water rescues they're only going
to be so useful when put up against
stuff like flying and fixing that's why
coming in fourth we have ourselves a
Rubble who gets to use his Specialties
of moving Boulders lifting things with
his Crane and digging holes 260 times
across the series it's roughly 63
percent and then right behind him we
have ourselves Marshall the fire pop
who's called on to help put out fires
with his firefighter gear and use his
ladder to reach people and need a rescue
248 times throughout the series roughly
60 which means that if you've been
following along you know that there's
only one pup left one final member of
the Paw Patrol that is objectively used
the least out of all the others and it's
not even close placing dead last in
seven out of nine Seasons ladies and
gentlemen the worst pup according to the
numbers with just 210 call outs and a 51
use rate it's Zuma do you feel that
loyal theorists do you smell that
delicious scent wafting through the air
that is validation my friends and all I
had to do to get it was to watch every
single episode thereby spending 150
waking hours of my existence here on
planet Earth to do it was it worth it
absolutely
except yeah this one comes with a bit of
a Twist you see data can certainly paint
you a good picture just doesn't
necessarily mean that it's an accurate
picture because there is a lot of nuance
behind those numbers my friends see
despite Zuma being called upon in just
half the show's missions have to give
credit where credit's due well he might
be used the least he's certainly not the
least useful when you look one layer
deeper into the data Zuma isn't the
worst pop there's one who's arguably
much worse one who barely succeeds one
who endangers everyone around them the
bad dog I'm talking about believe it or
not it's everyone's favorite klutzy
Dalmatian Marshall now you might be
thinking that this doesn't make a whole
lot of sense player fighting is an
incredibly important profession so how
could Marshall be the worst well for
starters yeah Marshall does specialize
in putting out fires which is a very
useful skill except there are only 11
fires throughout the entirety of the
series meaning that only 2.6 percent of
rescues are fire related and honestly
that's even me being generous two of
those fires are actually inside of
Marshall's dreams more often than not
Marshall's water cannons are being used
to paint Easter eggs spray tomato juice
or clean up messes even crazier is the
fact that Marshall has himself an entire
second set of equipment an emergency
medical technicians kit to help check
for broken bones and injuries and yet
this too is only used 17 times
throughout the series but worst of all
the thing that cements Marshall into the
worst pup position is fire trucks ladder
it is Far and Away the most used tool in
his Arsenal called out for 76 rescues 20
of the time the thing that Ryder finds
most useful about Marshall is setting up
a ladder so people can climb down from
high places but then Marshall can't use
the latter correctly it often misfires
or he uses it in a way that results in
people getting knocked down in some way
thereby making the rescue situation
exponentially worse in fact gotten to
the point where Ryder doesn't actually
trust Marshall to do his job correctly
he's even started implementing backup
plans for when Marshall eventually fails
Marshall I'll need you to raise your
ladder so Mayor Goodway can climb down
Chase you'll set up your net to catch
the mayor in chickaletta just for backup
and Ryder is taking action again against
this worst pop in the latest season
Marshals called out only 20 times to
help the fewest of any of the pups and
the lowest amount of times in his career
in short Marshall is being called out to
help less and less as the series goes on
and that's because he's a liability a
walking lawsuit so where then does all
this leave Zuma you know I called out
Chase Skye and Rocky because their skill
sets are so broad well the one thing
that zumas historically had going for
him is his specialty he's the water pup
that is his domain no one else is really
equipped for water rescues you don't see
Chase or any of the other pups
generating bubble Shields so they can
breathe underwater you don't see Skye
diving underwater to lift platforms or
at least you didn't until recently Ryder
is starting to box Zuma out too as the
push for new ideas and new merchandising
opportunities becomes a greater priority
for the show the pups have seen more
specialized event-based programming most
tend to stay in their own unique Lane
just giving the pups brand new power
sets that they didn't have before the
super powered Mighty pups the power
rangers-esque Dino rescue the medieval
themed rescue Knights of the race car
inspired Moto pop but then there's the
Sea Patrol where for 15 adventures all
the pups are basically just turned into
Zuma finally the Paw patroller being
presented with water-based missions only
for the work to be outsourced to the
rest of the team and to add insult to
injury that's not the only series of
special episodes to do it there's also
the additional six episodes of Aqua pops
and all of this is overlooking the times
that they turned into mer pops you know
Mermaid puppies that appear only during
a full moon come on try to stick with me
on this guys in short whereas everyone
else is generally allowed to keep their
skill sets and add to them by these
various spin-off Adventures Zuma is bit
by bit losing the only thing that he had
going for him you know that makes me sad
after watching these episodes I found a
new appreciation for Zuma he clearly
wants to help he's even excited to help
in situations where he can't is there
anything I can do sorry Zuma but I won't
need any of your tools for this job oh
okay that right there that is huge
passion for a job and wanting to help
especially when you're talking about a
business like this where there's
literally life and death being put in
the balance it is ear replaceable Zuma
is doing everything that's asked of him
and he's doing it well he's completely
competent and capable of doing whatever
writer tasks him to do it's just a very
specialized skill set and yet here's
Ryder boxing him out he's focusing on
the generalist pups puppies who can do
it all his top three All-Stars I suspect
it's to cut costs to streamline to make
things more efficient that way one day
soon they can all be replaced by The One
Creation that Ryder introduced at the
very beginning of the series Robo dog is
working a replacement that was ready to
go until it went haywire and destroyed
the town a robot that's been helping
with missions ever since always
observing always learning from the pups
in short not even the PAW Patrol's jobs
are gonna be safe from the AI Invasion
it's just that Marshall and Zuma are
first on the chopping block but hey
that's just a theory a film Theory and
I'm sorry Zuma I was wrong
[Music]
thank you